[Musique]
elles ont pris leur quartier à Coquelles
jusque dimanche voici les filles de
l'équipe de France de football en stage
une dernière préparation avant le départ
pour la Coupe du Monde en Allemagne
parmi elles la gardienne de Montpellier
originaire de Berck 38 sélections à son
actif fait plaisir ça serait fait un peu
plus de 10 ans que je suis pas revenu
ici c'est le gâteau c'est
une coupe du monde c'est moi ça sera ma
première celle de 2003 je me suis blessé
juste avant de partir
donc hâte que ça commence entraînement à
Gravelines il y a moins de public pour
les accueillir que pour les hommes mais
chez ces bleus là il y a des lyonnaises
fraîchement oréolées d'un titre de Ligue
des Champions j'espère que ça va nous
donner encore plus de confiance et
surtout pour pouvoir transmettre au
groupe bah cette cette confiance que
nous on nous avons atteint leur de cette
finale et puis pourquoi pas la donner
encore plus de ma comme on dit de peps
pour pouvoir aller le plus loin possible
dans cette compétition et aux premières
loges pour les admirer et l'équipe des
filles de Gravelines voir le haut niveau
au sein de gravine qui a une qui
évoluant des deux ça ça change voilà bah
maintenant on va profiter et puis on
verra bien ce qu'ils vont donner en
Coupe du Monde l'Allemagne le Canada et
le Nigéria sauront leurs adversaires
pour la phase de groupe niveau relevé
pour les derniers réglages l'équipe
rencontre donc ce soir la Belgique à
Newport match retour samedi à Calais au
stade de l'épopée
[Musique]